[Music]
hashtag Obama gay do you guys know what
that I did all day oh [ __ ] man
alright I feel like the inventor of that
word doesn't doesn't know what it means
the adventure in that word
I just thought Trump tweeting it was
really funny when the reporter was like
what is it
he was you know he is not you be
specific
you already know everybody knows
everybody know there's no more to be
there's some [ __ ] that he might say on
accident that's gonna get him killed
sure Oh more likely he's just an idiot
he does not know how to say these things
oh it's Trump yeah yeah I also thought
it's because if he said anything then it
it's it's it's grounds for slander or
it's clown grounds for deformation and
says defecation defecation is what it is
he said a lot of things that were
incorrect before where it's like it
sounds like fact but it's not so it's
not like that's a problem didn't he just
tweet out like they named Obama didn't
leave me any plan for how to handle this
and then they literally like left him
but he was like [ __ ] this and we cut
funding for it like a 62 page manual on
how to deal with pandemic yeah only 62
pages pretty light reading so the whole
base of Obama gay and the outline is
keep saying keep saying yeah yes oh it
sounds like a momma gay Obama gay yes I
always thought like you would get like
there is a there is a big controversy
about him perhaps being gay they also
think that Obama is a terrorist like
Osama yeah it's too close to the name so
that's just my Obama or Osama Hussein
Obama Hussein Obama who saying like
Brock who stock was saying okay three
drunk people just figured it out yeah so
leave him alone okay leave him alone
what do you want from us good the
general idea of Obama gay is the concept
is so Obama Joe Biden and the former
director of the FBI Comey and Ukrainian
oligarchs got together and created that
conspiracy of Trump working with Russia
and that's where it kind of all started
mmm well the I now the idea behind
Russia the Russia collusion conspiracy
theory which is it is now a conspiracy
theory because none of it was [ __ ]
confirmed they investigated but it
didn't come true Moeller said there was
no conspiracy about russia right he
found it and he listed in his report a
bunch of stuff that you know you could
argue salacious all this stuff but none
of it was like linked together into a
conspiracy that proved anything okay so
now the the the origins of all this came
from a group called CrowdStrike who
looked into the DNC server and they for
years on mainstream media everyone
talked about how Russia hacked our
democracy Russia hacked our election
right and then Facebook came out and
said yeah they bought some ads on
Facebook they were pushing a bunch of
[ __ ] and we all know Russia likes to
raise may have been elections that's a
fact so it wasn't much they they bought
like what a hundred thousand dollars
worth ads or a little more than that but
what we found out was that CrowdStrike
actually didn't know for a fact this
just came out with him past couple days
that the DNC server was hacked by Russia
that's the biggest mic drop about all
this I don't even know about this Obama
gate per se because most of its has to
do part of yeah Obama gate is a
rebranding really a spy gate right from
like a couple years ago spy gate like
the movie where there's a brother and
sister and they have the gadgets all
right and like three secret oh so
they're calling that Obama gate it's not
it's not Watergate no completely joking
with I don't know but spy gate spy gate
right the idea that when Trump was
running
for office there were FBI agents who
were sent into his campaigns true that
happened
it absolutely happened and they didn't
tell his campaign that they did that
right because they they were convinced
that maybe he was working with the
Russians and the biggest thing was the
fact that the FBI was investigating an
American citizen right but at the same
time the they also say that that happens
thousands of times a year so it was not
like a brand new thing but it's
significant because it's happening to
Trump's campaign well but it's it's okay
we're happy the predication for it is
what's [ __ ] up about it right so they
were able to take this dossier that they
say was confirmed or whatever by the
British government well early by this
guy named Christopher Steele who was
former mi6 they say that that is what
started all of this [ __ ] off right but
they were able to use that but really we
found out recently as an earth in New
York Times article that the dossier that
they used to frame the entire
investigation was based on Russian
misinformation so they were really
projecting a lot of the hey we think
they're gaslighting Trump in a way
because like yo you're you're working
with the Russians while we work with
Russians with the dossier that was paid
for by the DNC that was Russian
misinformation that Christopher seals
source from Russian sources that's
what's [ __ ] up about it right that's
the real scandal of this not this Mike
Flint [ __ ] unmasking [ __ ] all that [ __ ]
is wack and lame like that's the main
[ __ ] that's like people are talking
right now right so what that is
specifically is for the Mike Flynn thing
that you were talking about is
everyone's accusing and telling Michael
Flynn that he's lying to the FBI well he
admitted he did like the opinion he said
that I liked but he pleaded guilty thing
else he said when he realized this they
he would not have lied to the FBI
probably so here's what about this that
that I've seen right Mike Flynn lied to
the FBI right that's what that's what he
said he lied to the FBI in the main he
lied to the FBI what he lied to the FBI
about is what's fascinating right what
did he lie about so he was talking
during the transition after Trump won
the election he was Trump's advisor
foreign relations are
what'd he call that foreign policy
advisor and he basically was talking to
this guy named cos lyac on the phone
about hey Obama's trying to do all these
sanctions about what just happened with
you guys
the Russians interfering with our
election don't do anything don't ask
like the situation at all right that's
what he said don't don't actually at the
situation all the FBI had a transcript
of Mike Flynn saying all this [ __ ] so
then they go sit down with Mike Flynn
and they go hey we just want to talk to
you about this phone call no big deal
he's like should I have a lawyer present
or like no you're fine they actually
have a note that just got released to
was just part of this whole the part of
what people are saying is [ __ ] up
about what the FBI did is and I don't
like this for anybody that's what I'm
talking that's why look I have a free
Assange sure I'm okay I don't like it
when people use our intelligence
apparatus to frame Americans or to [ __ ]
over people who otherwise would just be
political enemies do you what do you
feel about the actual actions outside of
the framing to like you I we can be mad
at both right yeah so how what do you
feel about Flynn's actual actions in
which he reached out to Russia to say
that hey don't worry about it we're
gonna switch over to the new guy and he
doesn't mean cool don't worry yeah so
you're allowed to do that right so
that's that's the other thing right it's
like if you're moving in drop part of a
transition Europe and your job is to
talk about the actual transition no
those during the transition couldn't it
it's I think when you actually switch
from initiation the administration
you're still doing them the former
administration right so they tried to
curate so well real quickly so there's
this note that says hey what should we
do about Flynn here we're gonna bout to
interview him should we try to get him
to lie or get him fired or should we try
to camera what the third part of it
right but but the fact that the FBI
would go into it with the idea of
getting him to lie or getting him fired
from the Trump administration that's
what people go like either that's gross
right and then what was your second
question real quick how do you feel
about his actual actions like Flynn's
actions of him lying
well not him lying but he's at reaching
out to the government reaching out to
Russia and being like don't worry about
it don't worry about our time here you
know we got a new guy don't like he's
gonna be cool so in like going outside
of the administration
that's currently in place no course not
waiting until the switch where it's like
all right he's going on two new orders
he's going under the current orders he'd
be like don't worry about it right so
that's what's called that's what
everyone calls the the [ __ ] what the
hell's a call a turn no no no the
government knows it the rooster Donald
on my house the Hornet no it's called
something it's okay it's vloggin act
it's called the Logan act the Logan act
is that you as a Wolverine no the Logan
act is that an American citizen cannot
interfere with the foreign policy United
States of America right and nobody's
been tried for it for a hundred years so
exactly what you're talking about
is that you're like Kate I think it's
kind of [ __ ] up totally fair argument
you can make that argument ten ten times
out of ten you can make the argument but
is that legally wrong to do or illegal
right is the question
I thought the Logan Act you said was the
part that made it illegal no so the
Logan Act hasn't been successfully try
or used in a prosecution for 100 years
technically it's there yeah it's there
exactly so you could I could charge you
with something from the 1800s that
nobody is used as a law but because it
exists on the books they'll find that to
use it against you so I'm saying like
show you find me the man and I'll show
you the crime it's like that idea behind
it yes there are laws on the books that
are generally unenforced because many
people in our government don't they they
do kind of what they do and we don't
enforce every single law we all know
that like including perjury obstruction
of justice
oh hello like have you even pay
attention of the past couple years like
that's what I'm saying
so Obama Gate for people that don't know
what the hell it is the origins at his
core is an old allegation given to a new
name so as early as March 2017 Trump
alleged that Obama had illegally
wiretapped the billionaire businessman
at Trump Tower during the 2016
presidential election campaign so
they're comparing this alleged
surveillance to the Nixon era Watergate
scandal that's why Obama gave Watergate
it's wiretapping right so the following
year Trump claimed that the FBI had
planted an informant inside his campaign
dubbing the alleged conspiracy spy J so
it all came from that that's where it
all stems from but then then it goes
into the main allegation for the flynn
investigation and even though the FBI
had no legitimate reason to probe the
retired three-star general Flynn a
one-time Democrat served as the Obama
administration's top military
intelligence official before being
forced out of the job later in aligning
with Trump so Flynn is the guy you were
talking about that did the Russian thing
yeah yes and what I think is [ __ ] is
the fact that the Trump administration
is trying to say that unmasking Flynn is
[ __ ] up I don't think that that's
[ __ ] up shady the whole [ __ ] time
mm-hmm it happens all the time it's not
irregular well what's [ __ ] up is the
way that I think the FBI came at Flynn I
think that that should be looked into
because I don't like the idea that it
could happen to any of us right where
the FBI comes down on your ass and you
have no defense
yeah independent though like that's why
they exist because they're supposed to
be like neutral it's supposed to mean
that's always what the controversy is
now right people are always saying oh
you're there leaning this way they're
leaning that way
Oh FBI has always been against Trump
because they are these employees would
you know like the text transcripts would
stuff like that so it's kind of always
really hard to say anybody's independent
and that's always argument I mean
they're currently against Trump yeah and
look Eric Holder said that Obama he has
Obama's back like like the Attorney
General is appointed by the president so
the idea that the Attorney General's
independent for the presidency is not a
reality like nobody thinks that but a
lot of things that are kind of unfolding
right now it's too early to tell Obama
gait just recently blew back up it's
been something that's been going on
since 2016 and 17 but I guess it's
resurfacing now but some people
speculate that he's doing this to
distance himself from Comey because this
is like the first step to the whole
James Comey thing yeah so the James
Comey thing is the idea that Comey
he interfered with the 2016 election he
came out and said hey
we're reopening the investigation in
Hillary Clinton's emails because we
found a treasure trove of emails on this
laptop what can happen to that it just
stopped yeah well so the argument there
is that they found these these emails on
this laptop from Anthony Weiner who is
Huma Abedin husband and he got caught
talking to an underage girl and they
seized his laptop and they found all
this these Hillary Clinton emails on
them right so then they the FBI vetted
them over a weekend and in three days
Comey went from saying Hillary Clinton
is back under investigation - she is
clear
oh my thought probably interfered with
the 2016 election on arguably like if
you're talking about people going into a
voting booth and they're wondering who
they should vote for and they just heard
that maybe Hillary Clinton is still
[ __ ] up or whatever are still Bernie
yeah the argument I remember the big
controversy like oh she could be a
killer and then everyone goes and votes
for the other guy and they're like now
there's also the big controversy was
that the FBI director never comes out
and just makes a statement like that yes
let alone near an election so it's a
weird problem it's so weird and then and
then after the election we find out that
Comey working with what's called the 7
for the FBI there is a belief that well
it's not belief anymore come he
basically just admitted it like publicly
that he sent FBI agents into the Trump
campaign didn't tell the Trump campaign
which is by the way is Pratt is common
practice if you if you were to send if
I'm supposed to do something with the
presidential campaign it's pretty
sensitive stuff and we're in the
administrative part of the government
the enforcement part of the government
we should tell the campaign what we're
doing and the fact that they didn't is
spying yeah and that's the whole part of
it that people find [ __ ] up is like
you did spy just admit that that's what
spying is I'm I'm literally watching you
for some for a crime the FBI I'm not
telling you yeah it's like tapping the
mob and you should in this case they
should have told them that he was under
investigation mm-hmm that's it yeah so
that's all right that's what I think I'm
in the civil liberties I think that
people have a right to defend themselves
and I think that people have a right to
a fair trial even a president and so
just because you know I know for a lot
of people it's like well good they're
getting Trump it's good but it's
not good if they get them through
illicit means that's because it's not
due process to happen to the next guy I
bet you Bush spied on his [ __ ]
political opponents I guarantee he did
because if Obama was able to do it with
the FBI and what looks like the the the
rest of our intelligence apparatus he
also depends on the lens in which you
look at that right true cuz they might
have probable Kloss so is it like Oh is
he spying on his a political opponent or
is he spying on somebody who is
committing illegal acts that happened to
be on the campaign and that's the
argument that the other side of the
argument didn't think but what but what
Joe is saying it's like if you're under
investigation they should tell you hey
we're gonna not a lot of the times well
they don't have to they don't have to if
it's criminal
I mean it just depends yeah it depends
on motive yeah but where it started was
this guy named George papadopolis who
was a trump national security adviser
and he was in Europe and he got bumped
up against by a bunch of CIA people and
an Australian and they basically said
that he gave them information that
Russia was trying to spy or a now Russia
was trying to had information about
Hillary Clinton they were trying to
coordinate with WikiLeaks to release to
effect her campaign in a negative way
they were never able to approve that
[ __ ] by the way never able to prove it
that's what was Trump was they're trying
to say Trump was [ __ ] up with the
elections they're trying to say that
Russia interfere with our election yeah
they have now come out and said the
whole basis for that was this DNC server
that actually CrowdStrike says we
weren't able to prove that Russia
actually hacked that server so that
whole [ __ ] story has fallen apart and
that story by the way you got called a
conspiracy there is two years ago if you
even [ __ ] question that so now we're
kind of in the middle ground which is
what I said earlier when he said should
we talk about this today we're kind of
figuring out all the pieces they lock
into place because we don't know yet
it's just unfolding right now but I
think it was it was trending yeah on
Twitter and you know Trump was hashtag
Obama gating became Declassified right
yeah a couple of documents did it's an
including one about unmasking of several
so what happened say they find out Obama
was doing that probably nothing yeah I
mean he's done yes what's the whole
point of going
I mean looking into what how our public
got down a rabbit hole of the Russian
collusion conspiracy which distracted us
from the real issues which was
corruption within the Democratic
National Committee yeah and and frankly
crushing corruption in the you know
party and the same reason why none of us
frankly will ever have I think health
care is because [ __ ] like this just fits
one side against the other it's a WWE
and they're all fighting each other in
the ring and we all just watch and go
yeah I get it
but we're not you know is will good day
for lenses like why they bring up now
just like why they bring up a lot of
controversies like is it strategic
always do it yeah exactly that's what it
is it's strategic because of what the
news is focusing on and what we wanted
to focus on instead yeah and if they
instead put all that focus and attention
into something productive for us then I
think during a huge pandemic we wouldn't
have health care issues yeah [ __ ] like
that drives me nuts both sides are wrong
exactly and they have us arguing about
semantics and things that are completely
pointless and we waste our time getting
angry at [ __ ] Democrats [ __ ] Republicans
this and that when we should be dealing
with effective measures and things that
can really change it and they just
reauthorize the Patriot yesterday and a
part of that there was there's a
provision inside of it that says we can
seize anyone's internet history without
a warrant [ __ ] you Wow 30 Republicans
voted for that and 10 Democrats and so
it passed conveniently passed by one
vote so if you think that they didn't
sit down and figure out how the [ __ ] to
make that work make that split work and
make everyone look on the right side
you're nuts
[Music]